[موسيقى]
الاطفال في حج هذا العام مشمولون بخدمات
الرعايه والاهتمام حيث يقضون اوقاتهم داخل
دور الضيافه التي تم استحداثها لاول مره
في حج هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
زيد ونور والجمان براعم تتفاوت اعمارهم
بين الشهور والسنوات ينعمون هنا بجميع
الخدمات في عنايه خاصه حتى يتمكن دومهم من
اداء مناسك الحج بكل يسر وسهوله في زحام
المشاعر المقدسه
هو يمكن نروح
لمكه يسوون طواف ولكن جنب بابا ما تسوي
وعندما لازم تسمع الكلام كلام كلام الابله
ماما قالوا لي هنا وبعدين
يدوني بالبيت
الاطفال تتابع لوزاره الموارد البشريه
بتقديم خدمات متنوعه لاطفال ضيوف الرحمن
وكذلك المرابطين في الحج وهذه الخدمات
تتنوع من بين خدمه ايوائيه وهي تقدم
الاواله لهم طيله ايام الحج وكذلك
التقديم التغذيه والمشروبات الصحيه
ومجموعه من الفعاليات وكذلك الانشطه
الترفيهيه والثقافيه لهؤلاء الاطفال
[موسيقى]
الى وقت قريب كانت بعض الاسر تجد صعوبه في
اداء مناسك الحج بسبب حاجه اطفالهم الى
الرعايه وهي مساله جوهريه تحكمها ظروف
متفاوته ما جعل وزاره الموارد البشريه
تفاعل 13 دارا للضيافه والايواء بسعه تصل
الى 300 طفل تحت اشراف مباشر من مراقبينا
ومختصين في تجربه تخضع للتطوير المستمر
طبعا بيقدم برامج جدا رائعه اليوم يعني في
برامج ثقافيه يبدا يومهم من الساعه
السابعه صباحا
الاطفال ابدا اول ما يبداوا بالرياضه بعد
الرياضه ساعه تقريبا تقدم لهم وجبه
الافطار بعدها الوجبات على مدار الساعه
والسناكات وبرامج ترفيهيه ثقافيه وخدمه
المبيت بالاضافه الى خدمه الاتصال المرئي
مع الاهالي خلال الحج يعني يمكن للطفل انه
الطفل مع اهله وهو في الحج عمل الطريقه
الاتصال للمرئي والنت
تتسابق الجهات الحكوميه في السعوديه على
تقديم افضل خدماتها في موسم الحج والذي
يعتبر الفرصه الانسب لتقديم افكار
ومبادرات استثنائيه وذكيه تلبي حاجه
الحجاج وضمان رحله مليئه بالطمانينه
والسكينه لصباح العربيه من مكه المكرمه
سلطان السلمي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات